>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington D.C.
>> It sounds like you all have this,
you know this nugget of background,
in that area, poetry, religion, English.
And I'm guessing though that you're using them
in different ways now than
you intended, years ago.
[chuckle] And so I guess, I'm just wondering,
how does that specialty maybe come in to play?
Or where does that, how does that,
come across to a patron who's coming in
and needing some kind of assistance?
>> So I don't think English majors ever know
what they're going to be when they grow up.
[Laughter] when they get there.
So, it took me a long, long time to
figure out I wanted to be a librarian.
And lots of people say, "Ah, you're so lucky.
You get to be a librarian.
You must get to read all day long?"
Is that vision.
And I never get to read or
maybe just book reviews.
But, in terms of assigning the
"ask the librarian" questions,
we do assign those to the people.
And the question comes in
asking "What is the meaning
of life?", Cheryl has to answer that one.
[Laughter]
>> And I have gotten that one.
>> She has gotten that one.
Yes, she has gotten that one.
And both Peter and I get the questions
of "I'm looking for this book,
but I can't remember the title or the author.
But my mother used to read
it to me when I was little.
And I'm about to have a grandchild
and I want to read."
All of that kind of thing.
But also looking for information on Shakespeare.
A lot of literary criticism
questions, from all over the world.
And those are tricky, because it's hard to know
what resources they have available in Pakistan
or Iraq or; you know, where
ever, to study Joseph Conrad.
Usually not very much, and the notion
that everything's freely available
on-line, has to be explained.
You know, we have to burst
that bubble right away.
But, so either my colleagues will direct someone
to me or I'll get asked librarian questions.
Or as Cheryl mentioned, we're also the
recommending officers in our specialty.
So I will be monitoring our bookdealers.
Well English Literatures Canada,
Australia, New Zealand, UK and Ireland.
And so we have bookdealers in
those places and plans set up.
But I'm also reading other
materials, looking through new books
and deciding what we should get, so.
>> One of the things that the
digital reference team does,
is to offer a regular outreach
programs on different subject areas.
So we offer a monthly orientation to the
Library of Congress' on-line resources.
And I provide a few of those
presentations a year.
And that gives me an opportunity to highlight
some of our poetry resources in the course
of talking about the overall Library of Congress
website, and the materials available through it.
But as the poetry specialist for
our team, I've also been able
to offer a number of poetry related programs.
So April is national poetry month and when,
during the previous April, this April,
we offered a few programs related to poetry.
So one of the programs that I offered was
an hour long webinar on poetry resources
on the Library of Congress' website.
And so that allowed me to take
advantage of my background.
To highlight different areas of our site, that
educators and members of the public could use
to find poetry related materials
and incorporate them.
If they're teachers, into the classroom.
And we also just offered a
wonderful program on some
of the literary audio archives at the library.
Where I was able to bring in somebody from the
Hispanic Division to talk about the archive
of the Hispanic literature on tape.
And the archive of recorded
poetry and literature.
Which are two major audio archives related
to poetry and literature here at the library.
Which were recently made available last year.
So people can now go on-line and
listen to recordings of famous authors
and writers how have come to the library since
the early 1940s to read and discuss their work.
And so that's a fabulous resource and
based on my specialty, I had an opportunity
to highlight some of these amazing resources,
for people who don't always have
a chance to come to our library.
>> I want to jump in and
tell you Peter's really,
really active with the poetry
and literature center.
So he writes wonderful blog posts.
It's called "From the Catbird Seat".
Because that's the name of the
office for the Poetry Center.
And he's one of the major editors of the blog.
And writes wonderful pieces for that as well.
>> And Abby has made some great
contributions [chuckles] as well.
And I think that social media in general
is one of the ways that the Library
of Congress is increasingly looking to
extend our reach to non-traditional users.
And so increasingly we're turning to
Facebook, to blogs, to Twitter, to Instagram.
To make people more aware of our
resources in mediums other than coming
to the Library of Congress itself.
It's a great way to reach people who normally
wouldn't come here to find information.
>> And you asked about, you
know, what we imagined.
And actually as a child I did
want to become a librarian.
[Laughter] I'm not the only one here.
Because I just loved libraries.
But I think I imagined that I
would read all day, which I don't.
But one of the things, the marriage of library
science and religion, is interesting for me,
just because of the people who are
drawn to religion for whatever reason.
It's just a chance to meet
people and what they believe.
And or, it could be a very academic question.
Or it could be a faith based question.
But it, but to be, to stand there as
a reference librarian and be very open
to whatever it is they're trying to
find out, can be just fascinating.
And really it's such a privilege to,
to hear what they're passionate about.
So.
>> I think one of the things
that stood out as you have talked
about what you do, is just
how multifaceted it is.
I think when people talk to me about being
a teacher, they have a pretty, you know,
not very new understanding, of what
it really looks like to be a teacher.
>> Right.
>> Right. And so, I'm thinking the
same thing about the work that you do.
And, so there's outreach.
And then you're dealing with
social media platforms.
What's, what's one of the things, you wanted
to be a librarian and then things have changed
over time, what's one of the things that's
surprised you the most over the years,
about this job that you do each day?
>> I absolutely love my job for the variety.
The different things I get to do.
Recently, I worked on an exhibit.
Peter and I put together a small case.
So I never thought I'd be a museum
curator along with being a librarian.
But I think the best thing about my job, is
that I get to learn something new all the time.
Any, any, everyday there
are new questions coming in.
And as I get to research them, try and
find an answer, I'm learning along the way.
So, I think it's a job where
you can never get bored.
>> I also think that you're learning something
often through somebody else's curiosity.
And then you're curious about,
"Why is that like that?"
and, and you get the fun of playing with
it, but you don't have to write the paper.
[ Laughter ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.